welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and major spoilers for spiderman no way
home coming up so if you have not seen
this magnificent piece of spider cinema
you need to cease viewing this rectangle
right now and go to the big social
rectangle that is a movie theater
immediately but anyways if you're still
here um somebody's gotta tell me what
the hell they put in that fruit cobbler
because apparently your boy ned leeds
has
magic now like since when like how the
hell did ned lee's go from the guy in
the cherry to you're a wizard harry i'm
a what but you know not harry osborn
because he promised he promised he
wouldn't kill peter well i think i know
the answer so let's go on ahead and
speculate together my nerd baby
spiderlings because i think that ned has
secretly potentially possessed the power
to pop peter portals this entire time
and the reason why lies directly within
the secret agenda of the big bad
celestials or as i like to call them
aerogem and the holocaustograms but what
is this orange magic that wizards like
doctor strange and wong use anyway well
the good news is if you watch my video
on what the purple cracks over the
statue of liberty and spider-man no way
home r that released on the channel the
sunday the movie came out you've already
been slightly negated because you've
already have a basic understanding on
how ned uses orange magic like wong and
his intern steven strange if you just
really think about it no seriously if
you have not yet watched that video i
highly recommend you do so you can get
the most out of this video because i
believe that all of ned's orange magic
doctor strange's orange magic and the
orange magics of all the wizards of
kamar taj shang chi's rings and captain
marvel herself are directly tied to the
soul stone energy singularity a
singularity that the mcu earth is
uniquely familiar with as it is directly
tied to their orange glowing sun the
soul s.o.l soul
of mcu earth a very special soul placed
there by none other than the celestials
themselves so that the radiation waves
of the earth's soul could shower down on
humanity to aid us in our evolution
because that's what the soul stone
energies are it's evolution energy
because remember at the very beginning
of marvel's eternals film that released
earlier this year when the eternals were
just waking up on a ship that was parked
directly in front of earth's sun this is
because the ship was charging the
eternals orange golden energy of the
soul singularity like the eternals were
essentially these walking soul
singularity beings who could do all of
these amazing things through their soul
singularity powers and much like the
eternals were granted spectacular
mastery over their magic energy all the
humans of fcu earth have slowly been
being doused with this very same orange
sun's radiation of evolution over
millennia since the dawn of woman we
just get a lot lower concentrations of
it because we're not you know sitting
right in front of the sun like the
eternals were the very same type of
orange radiation that the sovereign used
to evolve their entire society into a
bunch of golden rude dudes and moody
prudes who pursued those who screw like
raccoons do causing adam warlock to
ensue the feud these are the same cosmic
rays of life and evolution placed there
by the celestials as part of their grand
experiment and it's probably the reason
why rocket raccoon picked up and tried
to steal the anulax batteries in the
first place because i think i have this
weird feeling that rocket's entire
evolution was probably in due to this um
evolution energy by the hands of the
high evolutionary and special thanks to
petal and the petal 2 card for
sponsoring this video petal is a company
that wants to help you succeed
financially that's why the pedal 2 card
is designed to help you build credit
when you apply for pedal 2 your banking
history may be used to instantly create
a cash score a measure of your credit
worthiness based on income spending and
savings it can help you qualify even if
you've never had a credit score before
pedal 2 visa card has no annual fee
you'll get 1 cash back right away on
eligible purchases and up to 1.5 percent
cash back when you make 12 on-time
monthly payments their app makes it easy
to track your spending make on-time
payments and manage subscription
spending the pedal 2 credit limit ranges
from 300 to 10 000 based on credit
worthiness which can help keep your
credit utilization low a key component
to building credit see if you're
pre-approved without impacting your
credit score it takes minutes to apply
online pedal is partnered with web bank
member fdic which issues the car as of
today the pedal 2 variable aprs range
from 12.99 to 26.99
start building your credit history go to
the link in the description box below
pedal card dot com slash new rockstars
today to find out more that's pedal with
a t pedal p e t a l card dot com slash
new rockstars much like they are in the
comics the celestials are all agents of
the cosmic entity eternity the cosmic
personification of the entire marvel
universe whose entire existence the very
point of eternity's creation is to
promote life so that living beings can
grow and change and evolve into higher
forms and so that the universe can
constantly be a universe of change and
growth and so the soul singularity is
the singularity of a little science
thing called nagentropy which is the
opposite of entropy which is you know
when energy breaks down into useless
heat energy so basically every time we
eat and every time we just basically
survive we combat against the energetic
entropy of our bodies and that's that
[ __ ] eternity and his rainbow science
babies do like the celestials were all
about installing these gigantic orange
suns that rain down these massive waves
of evolution energy that constantly push
mcu humanity along during their
evolution getting stronger and stronger
as their dna gets passed on from
generation to generation and hey as far
as unexpected golden showers go this is
kind of the best case scenario i feel
it's a lot less sticky and smelly i'll
tell you that so basically what i'm
saying here is ned's love for peter
caused his inner soul singularity powers
to manifest
through the really energetically
sensitive sling ring that he was holding
in his hand and i suspect that if mj was
wearing that very same sling ring and
was capable of not overthinking the
process she too should be able to
channel her own inner solar soul
singularity powers to do the exact same
thing this is why pretty much any human
can hop off a basketball court become a
wizard and then retire back to some
street hoops because all the ancient one
did at camara taj is teach terrans how
to use their own soul singularity powers
responsibly and use that power to defend
the earth from extra-dimensional threats
like germamu shimagura blah blah blah
and all ned magic fingers leeds was
doing and no way home was accidentally
using his desire to see his homie to
find other peter parkers that match tom
hall and peter parker's energy frequency
like ned was able to seemingly master
the portal making magic quickly because
he could visualize his best friend in
his heart really well and this is why i
believe that the portal did not close
when he wanted it to when the lizard was
chasing him and mj he was too
subconsciously worried about peter and
his well-being to close it so is ned a
wizard no because an earth wizard is
technically someone who went to school
in soul singularityology what happened
in no way home is ned discovering his
own power through the sensitive energy
absorbing conduit of the sling ring but
only if ned surrenders to the needs of
his heart and soul like steven was
forced to on mount everest by magic
caillou and i'm willing to bet that we
will be seeing wong teaching ned to
master his power as a full-on student of
soul singularity energy at camara taj
very soon so basically what i'm saying
is doc should definitely just consider
stopping by the sanctum and grabbing one
to eight sling rings if he really wants
to see what the power of the sun in the
palm of his hands feels like because
that's the soul singularity baby so
basically anybody who has been on mcu
earth for a long period of time and has
been exposed by all of this solar
radiation can use the magic of doctor
strange but only if they have enough
soul
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] but most
importantly you can follow new rockstars
wherever we are on social media and hey
do not forget to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can get cool
shirts like this and all of our other
hawkeye spiderman etc nerd merch over
there the really great stuff so head on
over there and hey go hit up our discord
if you want to continue the nerd
conversation just make sure that you are
18 years old and older and we can just
continue to talk about nerd stuff it's
fun but anyways thank you guys so much
for watching again i love you guys so
much have a really great day and i'll
see you guys next time bye
[Music]
you